Our inspiration
was Walker Evans, strictly,
and we looked at a lot of his stuff.
Our inspiration wasn’t
any other black and white films
but strictly photography.
Framing-wise, but also aesthetics.
Whenever I found anything
in corrugated iron, we stopped and shot.
Because I thought that was
the coolest thing in black and white.
And of course for Alice,
that was the first time I was
actually able to shoot in America.
It was quite an improvised shoot,
we were a tiny little crew.
And I wanted to start it
somewhere in the South
and we didn’t really have the money
to go all the way to Florida.
So we traveled down and I said,
“When we see the first palm trees,
we’ll start shooting.”
And that became North Carolina.
So for some reason it starts
in Surf City, North Carolina.
It was also the first
road movie that I shot.
That little film
"Alice in the Cities" was...
a way for me to discover
that there was a genre where
I could feel
like a fish in the water.
It was very liberating
to shoot with such a little crew,
and direct sound...
And on the road traveling,
and stopping wherever
I saw something that I liked
and then we invent a scene there.
Did you take a lot
of still photographs on that trip?
I was still
a Polaroid photographer.
And "Alice in the Cities"
of course is the film
where people saw for the first time
the I-670 land camera.
We got a prototype from them.
And even when the film came out
most people had never seen
this camera where...
the picture came out,
and then you saw nothing
and slowly it would develop
in front of your eyes.
So that was
the big fetish of the film.
But you were interested
in Polaroids before that.
What drew you
to Polaroids as opposed to Leicas
or printing in a darkroom?
I loved the idea
that they only existed one.
I liked the idea that...
you took a picture
and it only existed once.
Of course you could make copies
but I never did, and I liked
the idea that it was...
You took it once
and it existed once,
and it was just
one piece that was
entirely related
to that second that you took it.
There was
so much truth about the act,
and there is nothing
phony about a Polaroid.
Because you can’t fake anything.
You can’t interfere
with the process.
And once it’s there, that’s
what it is, that’s all you get.
I really liked that;
for years, I didn’t do anything else.
Later on, I went
to a larger form and negatives,
and took photography
more seriously.
But at the time,
that was the first camera
you could actually do selfies with.
The first camera you can
really be very spontaneous.
And to give those pictures away,
sometimes people
just didn’t know...
you could do something
and then hand it over to them
and say, “Keep it.”